okay so House of the Dragon episode 10
is almost upon us and it brings the
incredible season to a close and what's
no doubt gonna be a big send-off to not
only the show but also a couple of
characters the trailer for it is now out
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking it down talking about the
events in the book and also what point
we think this season is going to end at
because of this there'll be some Major
Spoilers so if you don't want to ruin it
then I recommend that you turn off now
the show doesn't adapt things 100 but
stuff is normally close enough that even
talking about the book could burn it all
down for you so there's your warning and
huge thank you for clicking the video
now let's get into the trailer
the greens are coming for you rhaenera
and for your children
you cannot bend the knee to the high
Towers they stole your Birthright
man standing around the painted table
urges her to plunge the realm into war
they Siege to the red keeper
send us
I swear towards the queen
your cause owns a power that has not
been seen since the days of old valyria
[Music]
now the episode is called the black
queen and as I'm shaking guess this is
in reaction to what happened in episode
9. the Council of the greens was formed
and aegon was crowned the king most of
the realm now sirenira is a legitimate
and thus she has to call together people
that still support her in the blacks we
have seen the greens murdering those had
to send from them and this of course
makes several houses realize that
they're trying to rule through fear they
view it as high treason and it
strengthens their word most of the
houses swore outs to an Era all the way
back in 105 AC and though some of the
heads have died since then most still
stand by their promise nothing episode
10 is very much gonna mirror the last
episode with people swearing loyalty to
the blacks whereas at 9 headed to the
greens whereas last time send it around
the green Council renera would
eventually go in to form the Council of
the blacks who I believe we've seen this
episode standing around the painted
table the urban with renice arriving at
Dragonstone on top of her Beast fresh
off the back of episode 9. quick
correction from our episode 9 breakdown
and in that I said I thought her Dragon
was maraxus actually couldn't remember
the name but I remember it started with
an m and just Googled rainy's Dragon M
and that's what came up probably changed
up now because of the popularity of it
but before it was marax's as a top
result I apologize and next time I'll be
sure to double check everything with you
in exchange for showing you my Feet
socks off as well now rainy swarns that
the greens are coming for her and as we
saw last week
Otto wanted to send assassins to take
her out I believe that we see a scene
like this playing out in the entry with
them once more meeting on the bridge
that leads up to the castle this
obviously Echoes episode 2 in which Otto
and the forces of King's Landing
traveled out there to get the dragon egg
back from Damon however this might
actually be Otto going to rain ERA with
terms in order to try and talk her down
from starting a war we do see someone
holding a page and reading from it so
I'm guessing this is all kind of going
over terms and conditions which they're
probably gonna skip like most people do
huge shout out to things story for
pawning out at the person holding the
parchment is runira and we can also see
on her head that she she's wearing a
crown he was appointed out that all is
there too and in the book he was the one
who came to deliver the terms he was
lambasted as a Trader and his chains
were taken from him which could explain
what happens after the swords are drawn
now Damon also talks about bending the
knee and he might even consider this in
the episode this would of course plunge
the realm into all and after the Decades
of peace that her father and grandfather
brought it is a risky move both viserys
and jaharis were known for creating the
most peaceful period in Westeros and to
go against this would in some ways undo
all their hard work or at least that's
how she might see it I don't know mate I
wasn't invited to this or the she-hulk's
writer room now in the book they talk
about the terms and say that allrinera
has to do is accept that aegon is the
king and she'll get to keep Dragonstone
she will be known as a lady but it seems
like she goes against this the teaser
shows raniera getting a crown which I'm
guessing will come after this meeting on
the bridge in the teaser we see error
canning over viserys's Crown which he
clearly stole from King's Landing in the
Burke Alison ordered for it to be locked
away in a vault so that aegon could take
egg on the conqueror's crown however a
servant ended up stealing this and they
fled the kingdom here though they've
given that role to Eric who is now
bringing it to renera in order to Crown
Heather rifle Queen now it's possible
that ranera goes into labor during this
episode after Anis delivers the news
that the greens are coming for her and
her kids we see her touching her bump in
the buck after her father's death she
went into labor and learned that her
throne had been taken away from her in
the source material the labor was
agonizing and it lasted for days with
raniera's screaming out monster to the
baby at one point it came out stillborn
with a dragon's tail and she blamed
Alison for not only killing the baby but
but also stealing her Birthright it
isn't the only child that she loses in
the episode either but we'll talk about
this more later on in the video Arena
stands beside Daemon out amongst the
Cliffs at one point and she looks like
she's been through hell I'm guessing
this will come after she gives birth and
it will be the pair realizing how much
Alison has taken from her it's plunged
everything into all our war I love the
shot where we see the Council of the
blacks presiding over the table the
orange glow created by the paint is of
course supposed to resemble fire and
hints towards the Flames that will rain
down on the land during the dance of the
Dragons this table was actually
commissioned by egg on the first during
his conquest and that allowed him to see
overall the Westeros so he could better
plot and plan his takeover whereas we
spent all of episode 9 at King's Landing
it seems like we'll be spending the
majority of 10 at Dragonstone this is
shown throughout the teaser with us
getting both day and night sequences
around the castle how about this trailer
also confirms that we will be heading to
Storm's end at one point we see josera
saying send us and he stood beside his
brother and cause sorry fiance's now
marker is placed down at Winterfell so
we could potentially visit there in the
episode or even pick up season 2 at the
location this will be where we meet Lord
Craig and Stark who could end up
becoming a big character next season I
pretty much view winterfellas being the
home of Game of Thrones yeah that's
right King's land and it would be so
cool to open up season two there now in
the work we learned that Alison had sent
out Ravens to almost all the houses in
the realm in order to try and rally
support for her side however the more
powerful places needed a personal touch
and though she sent out Eamon to Storm's
end in order to try and get them on her
side this is the same in the case of
raniera who ends up sending luceras out
to Storm's end in order to broker a deal
the name is symbolic in a number of
levels as the big scene there takes
place during a storm so yeah there's
storm and the season ends there so so
storms end anyway and it could also
refer to the final line from chapter 12.
this discusses how after viserys's death
the storm broke and the dragons danced
larys also brought up how important it
was in episode 9 before he was cut off
by Alison he wanted to warn her that
she'd see defeat without it and now he's
here to see defeat sorry did that joke
last video but it's it's a good one and
I'm I'm gonna do it a lot anyway back to
Storm's end now this is teased first in
the trailer by Eamonn pulling off his
eye patch after it was taken at drift
Mark he ended up placing a sapphire
stone in the wound witchy hid with an
eye patch this was our court so that
people didn't wince but now he's fully
in mode so he unveils it to the world
now in the bug Eamonn arrives there
first and he promises his hand in
marriage to one of boris's daughters
this will unite the houses secure storms
under the green side and also make it so
that raniero's side is outmatched useris
arrives late and due to him being
betrayed to his cousin sorry his what
friend he can't marry any of boris's
daughters aiming at this point demands
that he cuts out an eye and he says that
in exchange for this that he'll let him
live Eamonn goes to fight him but Lord
Bar says there'll be no blood shed under
his roof userus then storms out eh and
he then leaves on the back of his dragon
now at this point one of boris's
daughters that Eamon didn't pick towards
him and says that lucera stick his balls
along with his eye Eamonn then went out
in the storm and on the back of agar he
tracked luceras through the sky guy
elusirus's Dragon was smaller and faster
the storm slowed him down and thus Vega
was able to catch up Eamon killed him
and he ended up being known as the
kinslayer because of this it seems that
the series is changing up what happens
during the fight with it happening in
the courtyard rather than in the night
sky looks so good and watching vegar's
head slowly appearing over the wall lets
you know its own now it does appear like
they might take to the sky however the
way the part with luceris is presented
makes me think it might be something
else I think it could be him leaving
Dragonstone though it might also be
Storm's end the book talks about how
he's drenched when he arrives there so
potentially they shot us the start of
his journey these aren't the only
dragons that appear in the episode
either Judo raniera's side being
desperate she needs more and it seems
like Damon is going to Verma Thor this
is the dragon that belonged to jaharis
the first and it's one of the oldest in
the realm only being second of agar
Damon appears to be singing to it in
high Valerian and he promises that it
will get a new Rider this comes in the
form of Hugh Hammer who's gonna be a big
character in the series originally the
targaryens and valerians wanted it to
seem like only their bloodline could
ride the beasts this is because it made
them appear like gods and therefore
their rule wouldn't be contested they
had to bring in other Dragon Riders to
help and this was suggested by jacaris
out of the first person who attempted to
tame the dragon was burned alive Hugh
eventually stepped up and they could
reorder the events to have it happen
here after Damon calms it down now other
important moments with the character
happen when he grabs his sore dark
sister huge it out to brain pile up for
pointing out that this belonged to egg
on the conqueror's wife sister and he
rightly spotted that it's meant to
mirror how egg on II has the conqueror's
sword where as his sister slash wife
were one of them that sword now belongs
to Damon and whereas they once fought
alongside each other they're now held by
people on opposite sides he showcases
how the houses have fallen apart and how
this one strong bloodline is no longer
that strong that's not a strong open by
the way now the teaser ends with Vegas
snapping out of the rain likely grabbing
RX or possibly luceris I know I said
they might just keep it at the courtyard
but this could end up happening in the
sky which would be a great way to end
the battle anyway that ends the trailer
and it looks like it's gonna be one hell
of a finale the death of Lucero should
be a crazy way to close things off and
it would deal a crushing blow to an Era
that's because the back off of the
season has been all about protecting her
children this entire war was pretty much
started because they were seen as
illegitimate and it would be an
incredible way to end things with one of
their deaths that will be the end of the
series and I'm so sad to see it go it's
been an incredible 10 weeks and
hopefully we get an official
announcement of the Jon Snow one or
summing a Titus over to season two
either way that's the trailer and
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on it we are in competition right now
giving away three copies of top gun
Maverick on the 15th of November and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your your thoughts
on a trailer if you want some Elves to
watch make sure you check out our
breakdown of episode 9 ignore the thing
where I get the name wrong and uh yeah
head over there right after this and
give it a thumbs up please without the
way huge thank you for saying till the
end hope to see in the next one and you
have a great week mate take care
yourself peace